this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
view grants as well as performances and
without further ado Richard I'll turn it
over to you thank you say Jen can
everybody see and hear me raise your
hands if you can write this is working
I'm very happy to be able to talk with
you at least briefly this morning and
also to introduce our speaker first of
all I want to say that if you haven't
met her standing in for me is the
moderator today is seegen yen Stevenson
who is our assistant director for the
u.s. Asia Technology Management Center
at Stanford and siegen is also very
active in organizing events and helping
out with professional associations
around the Bay Area so I'm delighted
that she can be the moderator today I
also want to say a special thanks to
Alan miner who is with us today the Alan
minor foundation is providing us with
some additional support financial
support for this seminar series and I
hope that you'll stay around afterward
and enjoy the refreshments that this
allows us to provide also it'd be a
great chance to meet our speaker and to
meet with Alan just to mention briefly
what a small world it is when I
communicated with Alan before the
session today he pointed out that one of
his portfolio companies blue spark is
actually taking part in the project that
Professor John will be discussing today
so our speaker today is Professor Lynn
John who is usually with jing hua
university but this year he's a visiting
associate professor at stanford
university in electrical engineering his
research focuses on wireless sensor
networks and distributed data processing
and also information theory professor
Zhang is co-author of more than 40
peer-reviewed technical papers and he's
also on five US or Japanese or Chinese
patents
Oh professor Johnny and his team also
were the winners of the I Triple E ACM
census 2010 best demo award he's done
various things like developing a
structural security surveillance project
at the bird's nest stadium in Beijing
before the Olympics that played a
critical role in the construction of the
facilities oh I think that the best
thing for me to do is to turn over the
microphone to Professor John and let him
talk about this on wide area since her
network that is being tested out in
Beijing using taxi cabs sounds like a
fascinating idea i'll listen for a
little bit but then i'm going to have to
run to a different skype call pretty
quick professor John thank you so much
for being with us today oh thank you
thank you for the introduction this lady
and gentleman I think is a perfect
example that internet talent technology
is bridging the gap between the two
sides of Pacific Ocean literally so I
think today is a great event that we
have this chance to communicate about
the latest technological development in
China so before I start I like to have a
little knowledge about my audience by
showing off hand how many of you have
ever visited Beijing wow that's great
thank you seems that we have a group of
the Beijing fence or Chinese fans that
we have a common frame of reference to
discuss today I'm going to introduce a
experimental system that we deploy in
beijing city using the a bunch of taxi
cab to convey the mobile sensors that to
capture the dynamic of the city the
pollution the temperature humidity the
population the migration pattern of the
population so on and so forth so before
I catch into the technical details I
will
to give you a preview of the comparison
between Chinese cities and the US cities
oh I'm punching the wrong people that's
fun so this is a better i got from the
wikipedia describing according to a
statistic in 2010 and 2011 respectively
the area and population of the city of
Los Angeles and the city of Beijing
didn't see the city of Los Angeles is a
area about 1,300 square kilometers and
population about 4 million and that
those of Beijing are about 170 170
hundred square kilometers and 20 million
so that is too bad that is not too bad
right the population density amongst the
two city are comparable right beside
except that Beijing is a slight larger
but if we look at the central area of
Beijing the situation are completely
different the center of Beijing is only
about 1,400 square kilometers but has
about some 12 million population in it
that is to say the density of population
in the central area of Beijing is about
four times of that of the city of Los
Angeles for those who have living
experience in Los Angeles imagine how
crazy it is to drive in in such a big
city and the imagine twice as crazier
that in Beijing it's it's just something
we have to be very careful 2222 for the
future plan of the city so let me show
you a picture this is a picture taken by
Weibo user some of you may know that
label is a Chinese version of Twitter
and post it in last December this is a
picture of the southern area of beijing
city in early winter morning in december
two thousand eleven
so the picture shows the city was
covered by I don't know smog or or fog
somebody claimed that it's a beautiful
early winters in scenery and somebody
Glynis a heavy pollution is it scenery
or misery we don't know ironically we
have two entirely different
interpretation of this scenario we have
a reading from the official Ministry of
Environmental Protection Bureau saying
that the pollution of that morning was
moderate and on the other hand there was
a reading from the US Embassy in Beijing
saying that the particular late madhur
2.5 was literally off the chart so what
what was the what was the real situation
in Beijing we just don't know but if you
look if you look at the distribution I
mean the geo distribution of the
observer Observatory of the of the air
condition you will only see a very
sparse few dots in the large area of
Beijing that is to say we have a very
poor and sparse understanding of the air
pollution and it's dynamic in the city
of Beijing I think this situation is the
same in most other cities in China where
the population are highly concentrated
in the urban area and very few
population in the suburban area well the
situation is that we don't actually
understand the city the dynamic the of
the air pollutions where are they come
from how do they dive use a lot of time
and over the over the space and there
are some southern changes this is a
picture taken in the summer in August in
Beijing and the poor car was with was a
with put over there and I was
overwhelmed by the decider southern ring
in a few minutes and we also see the
very bad traffic in the big cities and
if you are a driver I'm sure you don't
want to see such a badge while you're
trying to take a writer well this is
because the very fast dynamic of the
city everything is changing but the the
management is not as fast and from a
control aspect view if the channel is
with Layton sees that the control is
very hard to achieve stability yes yes
it's like a challenge to your drive you
yeah so we want to have a real time
better in finer grained understanding of
the city how can we do that so there are
challenges to provide such kind of
technology or system including we have
to deliver a gigantic ball on data from
heterogeneous sensors from distributed
locations and we need to cover a large
area with a very high spatial resolution
let's our our requirement so if we if we
look at beijing city again we find that
this red box covers the so-called Fifth
Ring Road the inner area of the Fifth
Ring Road which is considered as the
urban area of aging well another aspect
is at the time that a time axis when I
was in in college some
20 years ago the tsinghua university the
campesinos like a satellite city of
Beijing we have take a very long bus
ride across a farmer's land until we
reach central part of Beijing and now
too high is actually one part of the
urban area very crowded area so this
area approximately 600 kilometers in
area covers more than half of the
population of the beijing city but areas
only approximately 110 when tens of that
area of Beijing so how do we cover this
area this relatively affordable cost how
do we provide the support to versatile
kinds of applications now we are
considering air pollution a monitoring
of air pollution temperature maybe
sometimes in the future we have some
application we don't leak we cannot
imagine this moment right and we also
want to make the system scalable now we
are talking about a few hundreds of
sensors maybe in a few days of years we
are talking about the hum a few billions
of sensors in the city cover everywhere
in the city so how do we make the
communication network scalable that is
another challenge ok so this is our
solution this is our salt what I'm
showing you on this video is the
trajectory data of the Beijing taxicabs
we collect it the location the real-time
location of about one-third of Beijing
taxi cabs in Beijing that is about
30,000 taxis there about altogether
about 19,000 taxicabs imaging and this
is the data set we collected in in the
in the month of May in two thousand I
four whole months with sample interval
of one sample per minute and you can
read from the data that it's very
coarse-grained visualization of the data
set the location of the taxicabs the
traveling direction of the speed
indicated by the color codes can
portrait the network the road very
accurately and precisely and there are a
lot of information embedded in the in
the in the group of taxicabs and imagine
if we can give them
sensors say mounted to the roof of the
taxi cabs how many information can we
collect found them and another problem
is how can we deliver actually deliver
that information bits from the taxi cabs
well an easier way is to give the cell
phone right to every sensors it's not
too bad right only a few tens of
thousand that's okay but we're not
talking about this scale we're talking
about a few hundreds of millions or even
billions of sensors future we'll be
deploying the city in the future how can
we do that so the research problem or
the meats for the research is one that
when the sensing tasks meet the mobility
we have a lot of merits of the system
first mobility will improve the
communication capacity if the some of
you are majorly in the information
technology will read that actually the
mobility of a wireless sensor network
will be good be beneficial to the
capacity of the whole network and also
mobility increase the coverage of the
sensor system with only one taxicab we
can literally cover a large portion of
City as long as the taxi driver is very
hard working right luckily most the
Chinese taxi drivers are very
hardworking they work double shift and
24 by 7 so you can see a random
trajectory tremors across the city and
all the time that is very good for our
task right okay this is what we did we
develop this small car boxes with a
micro control unit and a bunch of sensor
units including carbon monoxide
acceleration meters gps temperature
humidity humidity and light and we give
this boxes out to the tour bus drivers
and asking asking them to amount the box
to the roof of their tourist buses and
then they are doing their regular
business okay picking off people from
some hotel and jogging them off to to
the hottest tourist attraction points
and they also suffer
the traffic as every every one of us
does and also we we collect location
data or the trajectory data from the
biggest debating taxi company covering
about one-third of the group the whole
group of taxi cabs is about 27,000 to be
precise 27,000 trajectories so we did a
little bit experimental system
deployment based on this hardware and
system configuration well from the
system a point of view there are a few
layers of technology we should be
considering at the designing period
stage of the of the system first how do
we do the communication that is to say
the physical layer and Mac layer how do
the taxicab talk to each other or talk
to the Central Station while they have
some data to upload well there are a
bunch of communication technology
available some of them are commercially
available some of them are even
standardized so this is a question like
we only have to be we only have to worry
once in your life and then we forget
about it so we have two candidates for
this technology for these two layers
sorry one is the a22 dot11 p which is
the standard vehicle-to-vehicle
communication technology basically it's
a it's a it's a Wi-Fi technology the
same technology Wi-Fi but using the
different band and reduce the speed by
half so that the reliability between the
fast moving vehicles can be guaranteed
so this technology has been sterilized
and I heard from some friends in the car
business car manufacturing business say
that in the US this technology will be
enforced by legislation in a few years I
think we can expect the same trend in
Asian countries in China so the original
rationale for this technology is for
safety
when two cars are likely to collision
into each other the technology will give
a warning message to the driver or even
step on the pedal in place of the driver
if you like so we can take the advantage
of the car to car connectivity as the
information dissemination channel for
our sensory data but this technology is
still immature a little immature the
chipset are very expensive for at this
moment so instead of using that we're
considering another technology called 15
for 15 old voice has another more
popular name at zigbee it's a very
narrow band low-cost short-range device
to device communication technology but
it was not designed originally for the
mobile scenarios well in the road how
good can they do so we did some
experiment we deploy a test bad test the
point-to-point a packet dropping rate
under different traffic scenario bad
traffic moderate traffic and empty road
and what we got is a pretty promising
results showing that the reliable
communication radius of the 15 dot for
technology is about 70 to 200 meters in
typical Beijing road collision depending
on how bad the traffic is well basically
the reliable communication rain is
heavily dependent on the traffic the bad
trip the worst traffic is the shorter
the communication ranges but well you
can consider if the traffic is so bad
people are stuck in there so there are
longer encounter time so that the car
can talk to each other so more data can
be exchanged right so these two types of
technologies are major physical and Mac
layer technology will consider and
comparing the cost we finally decide to
use the cheaper one the 15 dot 4c
technology
and we have the commercially available
chipset in the market a few bucks a
cheap very cheap right okay then this
part we can we can forget about it it's
not the most challenging part then we
come to a upper layer just now I was
saying of course we can give a cell
phone to each taxicab drivers so that it
can report the data in real time but
that's good but not the most challenging
or a scalable solution because one day
when the number of participants in this
sensor system increase we will face the
scalability problem probably the china
mobile will not be happy to support so
many number of mobile sensors
considering their cellular networks
capacity you know we have to split their
cells that will cost a lot of a lot of
deployment costs but actually those
sensor driven cell phones are not
generating a lot of revenue they're very
narrow band data right so what we're
thinking is a hybrid system we have a
lot of mobile carriers of sensors in the
city only a small portion of them are
equipped with the cellular access to the
data set once the data get to this cars
they go into the central database
immediately and the other cars are
relying on the car to car communication
technology short-range more bandwidth
sufficient but and also low cost but we
can trade the efficiency of the cost of
the system with some latencies you can
imagine in such a way actually the data
must wait to somebody with a cell
cellular module reach the communication
radius of the cargo communication link
so that the data can be uploaded to the
to the data center that's something we
have to sacrifice its trade off
basically so the problem is
we have a very good process and some
cons about the system the good thing is
the vehicle are supported by constant
power supply so we don't have to worry
about it energy and the storage on board
is virtually infinite as the flash
memory is getting cheaper and cheaper
and the mobility pattern of the taxi
drivers and the buses are predictable
either statistically or
deterministically is predictable and
also we have some challenges well the
topology of the network are changing are
not entirely predictable well we have a
very limited inter contact duration and
the local capacity of the channel either
is a 11 p or 15 dot C are very limited
so how can we use the short encountered
duration very wisely so that the sensory
data can be very efficiently upload to
the data center or base station so this
is a formulation the problem one thing
we should mention is that the delivery
of the sensory data after its generated
by some sensor must be deadline
constraint I mean if the data is stuck
in the network for say more than four
days or a week then it's considered
useless we want some some real time is
not exactly real time some sort of real
time is that is a some level of latency
can be tolerant it but not infinite
latency so the problem becomes how can
we use the inter contact opportunities
very wisely to replicate the data set
the data packet in the network so that a
data packet can be delivered to the data
center within the deadline with very
high probability or with the highest
probability is no no I was just trying
to give an example four days is too bad
actually we set it to four hours in our
experiment and I'll show you in a few
slide that the for our deadline is not a
very bad one it's
not very hard objective to reach I'll
show you in a few well I will not go
into too much detail or technicalities
basically let's think about the picture
okay a few tens of mobile taxicabs are
driving a tremors the city let's say
it's a random work and they ran into
each other frequently in when then when
they pass it a sensor a roadside sensor
we download the sensory data to their
onboard computer and when to taxi cabs
run into each other they exchange
according to some protocol their their
data that we processed well how to how
do we manage the exchanging behavior of
the datas so as to maximize the the
successful delivery of sensory packet to
the to the data center within the
deadline that's that's a problem so it's
not very obvious there is not very
obvious solution to this because if you
think it think about it more carefully
it will find out the current position
it's not exclusive for the optimality of
the system actually the current position
relying on your future decisions only
one second before the end of world you
can write out a very clean form of about
how I can do the optimization I do this
then I will maximize my my my delivery
probability but two seconds before the
end of word I don't know I have to rely
on my next second behavior to decide
what I'm going to do right now so I have
to go into the go to the end of the
world and go back so the optimization
problem is not a trivial one and it's
very very computational unfriendly so
what we decide to do is just a heuristic
we reduce the computational complexity
in the price of the loss of some sort of
optimality but the result is good I will
skip this
equal part and show you the result ok
this is the delivery ratio of the
sensory data from different part of
Beijing to only one base station located
in the Tiananmen Square ok the center of
Beijing I suppose there is only one
place tower in the center of Beijing and
we have about 4,000 taxi cabs involved
in the game and there is one sensor in
each cell the cell is in the in the size
of one kilometers by one kilometers and
what is the delivery ratio of the of
each cell within four hours the answer
is if we use 4,000 taxicabs the
probability that no matter where it is a
sensor data can be delivered back to the
base station within four hours over
eighty percent so what we need to do is
deploy some 4,000 very cheap car boxes
to the taxicab drivers to the taxi cabs
and deploy as many as you like sensors
in the city in a within the the Fifth
Ring Road it's a 6600 square kilometres
and we set the deadline 24 hours four
hours not to lose constraint it's ok but
consider how let how little you have to
put into the system only 400 taxi cabs
give them each a cell phone or a car box
and then you can collect virtually over
eighty percent of sensory data within
four hours so this can provide the
support remember I don't put any
specific constraint on the type of of
data it can be any type it's later here
ok then what do we do what do we do to
to take the advantage of the the data
remember data is not knowledge it's just
a a gigantic volume pits what do we do
ok I'll show you some example the first
one the first one is what we did for the
manager of the city we want to know what
are the hot spots of the
well basically by hot spots I mean where
are the most popular picking up
locations and dropping off location of
taxi cab or drivers sorry of passengers
then we did so called clustering
algorithm over all the picking up
jumping off location in Beijing we have
entirely no somatic level information
over the location we do not know where
it is suppose you're you're you are from
from from the moon you don't have any
information you just do some Universal
clustering algorithm and you reach see
you get is a discolored cluster and then
we ask where are they interestingly they
are they are some somatic level
informations for example this is a very
big residential complex in thousand area
of Beijing and this hotspot emerged only
in the Russia after the rush hours
people are getting home from there look
and of course those two clusters are
terminals of the Beijing International
Airport and this is beta and two huh and
of course central business unit and some
bar areas in here I'm sorry its embassy
US Embassy this is a bar area see
they're quite close to each other okay
so we have the we have the cluster of
the dropping off of a pickup locations
and what's next still we want to know
how how are people moving in the city
along with in the different time of the
day so instead of clustering the points
we try to cluster the point pairs the
picking up and dropping off location
pairs and those are indications about a
moving pattern of the taxi passengers ok
this is the clustering result in 5pm of
35 a.m. this is in the during the lunch
time very hot and this is in the late
evening almost a midnight
interestingly we found some some some
heuristics some some hints on how to
make the public transportation system
more efficient more more reliable for
instance during the midnight clustering
result we found a never existing cluster
between the CBD and somewhere in tongues
oh it's not color here but there is a
very heavy cluster between these two
points and during those our the subway
system is not operating that's why
people are taking taxi cabs very very
tensed OD pair origin destination pair
appears during those hours probably this
is a good indication that mayor of
baiting should consider enhance the
operation or prolonged operation hour of
the of the of the subway to to
compensate those traffic okay and some
ongoing work are including gave taxicab
drivers some indications on how you
should use your gasoline wisely to pick
up the next passenger who will give you
the longest texted right very shortly
where should you go or what should you
do some statistic indication or advice
to taxi drivers so basically this this
information can be can be a data set
that we use to train the mark the market
in a more efficient to a more efficient
way ok this is the something we generate
for the further for the management for
the manager of the city and how about
small business interestingly we find
some other interesting application based
on just the trajectory information of
taxicabs well you know for those who to
taxi right in Beijing they're on some
taxes there are small screens for the
backseat driver I'm sorry for the
backseat passenger and you can watch
advertisement or even trailers of movies
on the screen somebody claiming is a
very annoying but most likely it
so what if I can push the most useful
information to the passengers instead of
broadcast and rotationally and blindly
so what are the site information what if
I can predict the dropping off location
only after a few minutes heavy
trajectory by heavy trajectory I mean
the batch of the hexi was was turned
down meaning this is heavy car there are
some passengers and I learned the
trajectory only for a few minutes and
then I can predict the dropping of a
location very precise very accurately if
I can do that basically I can sell this
piece of information to the mobile
advertisement website so that it can
pick the most useful or relevant
information to the passengers the answer
is yes we can do this yes after all
where were to go right so I and also a
lot of character will use gps to help
them or not yet and you like you already
get some information on where the
destination is like yeah I think that's
another must be another very huge
business model you can ask the taxi
driver to operate some keyboard to
select the most appropriate sets of ads
that is the shown to the to the to the
passenger and maybe you can figure out
some reward system a give give the taxi
drivers and some credit to to to
incentivize them to do this right but we
are thinking this from a very technical
point of view but what about the just a
pure data mining and find out the
drop-off location um whether the belief
behind this is the city is a very
heavily constituent system and people
are human being are habitual animals so
only after few turns we can we can fall
cast the probability distribution of
their dropping off locations
interestingly basically this is a
learning process of we consider this a
high order Markov chain it's learning
from
a bit basically we find that during the
weekdays we can do as good as ninety two
percent of accuracy to predict the job
of location only after five steps and
during the weekend the accuracy dropped
to some eighty-seven percent then we we
thought about it well it's a it's
intuitive because during the weekend
people are in tend to be more random
right but during the weekdays you you're
more habito following your regular
routes so that's some result and we can
also use the very dense trajectory data
set to to figure out how good a
transaction is configured right i
noticing in the u.s. most intersections
are equipped with circuit with loops
when there is a k is a car the the
sequence of the signals will be adapted
adapted to the to the existence of cars
but in most chinese beijing
intersections the traffic or so bad was
so heavy that the circuit system does
not function so we have to schedule the
timing of the signal very wisely so that
the throughput of the intersection can
be maximized how many seconds you can
give to the left turn to the go straight
into the right turn that is the question
to answer so by mining the taxi
trajectory data set we can figure out
that right we can figure out how bad the
traffic for the left turn lane is and to
the other links with respectively so
those are some learning algorithm for
the for the trajectory data set let's go
to the more fun part the pollution okay
remember we have a bunch of carbon
monoxide sensors deploy to the tour
buses we have about thirty something
tour buses roaming the city all the time
they are sampling the city it's very
simple right some of the city all the
time and we have a random trajectory
modulated random sample in the city
distributed sparsely in a time spatial
continuum then we want to reconstruct
the diffusion process of the pollution
where are the sources of the pollution
and how do they dilute in the city
that's a problem where we're trying to
to answer luckily we are we are
supported by some state of art
statistical signal processing algorithm
mainly developed by professors of
Stamper including some some professor in
the State Department and W department
here so it's called compressive sensing
basically we do not have to cut a lot of
samples in order to reconstruct the
fine-grained diffusion process of the of
the pollution we only have to cut a few
of them and then we can do the
reconstruction I will show you the
result ok this is the diffusion of the
carbon monoxide the concentration of
carbon monoxide in beijing city the
reconstruction was based on 30 taxi
sorry 30 tour buses reading with the
carbon monoxide sensors on the roof of
there on the roof of the buses the the
white lines in the in the in the in the
map in the figures are the second ring
road third fourth and fifth ring roads
of the beijing city so that will give
you a frame of reference of the the
granularity of the reconstruction
interestingly we found a very heavy a
big concentration of carbon monoxide in
the southern part of aging it's a little
bit weird to us at very beginning
because we thought the carbon monoxide
was mainly contributed by bad traffic or
core burning heating in winter some part
of beijing are still using the core
burning hitting in the winter but it's
not what what is that we don't know and
we
figure out eventually there was a
chemical plant in southern part of
Beijing that contribute some of some of
the carbon monoxide pollution to that
area and you can see the diffusion
process of the of the of the over the
city well we have to say the current
validity of the data set is not perfect
yet because the number of cars equipped
with sensors are still small only 30 but
we have some theoretical a bound
analysis set giving the number of the
cars increasing we will reach the
accurate we reach a very good accuracy
of the of the map very fast even faster
than the number of cars equipped with
sensors much faster than that that's
good right the deployment cost of every
sense it's not that bad okay so
virtually all the application I
mentioned here require very very
powerful computational infrastructure
right it's good because the computation
are becoming cheaper and cheaper
nowadays so this is the the picture we
are showing to our to our sponsors okay
we have different kinds of sensors like
the route sucking water from the soil
and then we store the data is some data
infrastructure doing very complicated
computational data mining commutation of
sensing the big data in urban area and
then we can generate different kind of
understanding of this data which are
either good for citizens in the city or
the manager of the city and on the other
aspect we are looking at the
computational power of the human being
ok this is a figure i think is very
intuitive this is the year the access
x-axis is the time of the year and the
why is the computational power ok um the
blue curve here is the computational
power of the world number one super
computer and
the the blue curve here is number five
hundred supercomputer in the world
basically we consider that the larger
the supercomputer and not so super
computer and the orange curve here is
the summation of all the supercomputers
in the world the computational power
remember the y-axis in the logarithm
skill so you can see the picture and
this is my iPad capability and in 1995
my ipad is a supercomputer and this is
my laptop and in 1998 my laptop can be
considered as a supercomputer in that
here and you can see that in only six to
eight years the number one supercomputer
in the world will be hardly considered
as a supercomputer and only in 12 years
the summation of all the supercomputers
computers no power will hardly consider
as a supercomputer imagine how fast it
that the development is and also people
are thinking well supercomputing is very
time consuming it's very expensive but
the fact is is not true let me show you
the power consumption of the
supercomputers and some other stuff okay
this is the power of my iphone to watts
this is a regular average housekeeping
power some 600 watts in the US and this
is the power of f1 formula one race car
and this is a power of a k computer k
computer is the number one the fastest
computer in the world is in japan and
this is the computer commutation of
power of all the google facilities in
the world that is a global google power
and this is the power of boeing 747 the
maximum power of course mains auto
taking off it's approximately 10 times
of the k computer the number one super
come to the world and it's only one
third of the global google power
consider how much work and a google do
in a second and consider compare that to
a taking of a boeing commercial jet that
is not too bad right considering a
doctor Dasher is a hosting Lisa this
this lecture from from from Japan and
say using some internet power and
compare that to to travel back
physically using a on the commercial jet
it's it's it's quite okay so what I'm
trying to say is a computing is not a
problem we can we can take the advantage
of the of the power efficiency of the
supercomputer to enjoy the power of the
computational sensing to understanding
to understand better the urban areas so
my idea is in a nutshell well
understanding urban dynamics are is
extremely important helpful to increase
the city life especially in developing
country like in China everything is
changing within the decade and the
moving vehicles in the city can be an
ideal carrier for the sensing tasks and
computation is playing a very vital task
important role in the information mining
and providing the service so finally I
would like to thank to my students and
my colleagues in team ha a bunch of
crazy guys doing all sorts of the things
you can or cannot imagine and we also
have a support from Cisco system and
Beijing and changing government that
give us very generally generously the
data set that is the most critical part
of our research and I also thank you for
your attention and I won I would like to
take questions thank
so insightful to understand now in the
crowd sourcing acid on the aggregation
of data and some of the commercial
applications are associated with this 45
I'll open the floor to questions and
whatnot so if anyone has the questions
although I do start there's discussions
why do you choose vehicles instead of
like black bothersome like many nice
bolt laptops microlights person I'll
save levels um because we need mobility
only one sensor can cover a lot of
carries for the pollution it's a highly
spatial temporal correlated you don't
have to assemble the same location all
the time you can you can sample and move
sample and move the same job that cover
a large area confessions one how do you
approach the infrastructure for all the
back end at academy is this a cloud
platform based architecture for that
part second flash we mentioned a few
pretty business Idol of mine come out of
it and I'm curious about the college
Ching hai University cuz it with the
sheen process how the process works for
commercializing university research in
China and what sort of ideas you or your
team that brings the commercial venture
yeah sorry to my glasses the first one
is technical one how do we access the
back-end infrastructure actually we only
deploy a few a small portion of the hexi
caps with the cellular models and those
are considered as the connection the
binding to the infrastructure and we
have a super computer cloud behind the
think that is a star is storing and
processed the data collected from
distributed sensors the second question
is you know ching hai's a pub
University and at very beginning we got
support from Cisco China well John
Chambers was that my university to
unveil the joint lab and that is part of
Cisco's commitment to the China green
industry transition they call this way
and also the a lot of local government
are quite into this ideas because they
want to have some sort of Khalid heist
support to their decision-making instead
of some empirical experience spaced
support so we are generating like
consulting report to the local
government that is the potential model
where we are considering and in in both
in any way sinha main campus in Beijing
is supplying a row as a fundamental
researchers and we have a different
research institute in different cities
that is in charge of that are
responsible for the spinning off
companies and supporting local customers
so given that you only sample mexico's
one time I minute how do you know when
they picked up people when they like
juggler um you know there is a lot I
don't know what what's the story in the
Bay Area I took few times that the
yellow cab there's yes available or not
available sweet and that switch that one
big information is sampled by the the
car box Josh focus is the product of a
person making it can very funny you done
it in their research you mean the source
of the data no you want to say the right
for traffic and pollution Connors well
that is very party to keep that gated
their research oh that's a that's a data
set that we
we shared as a as academic resource you
can you can basically download the data
from our from my labs website oh one
more slide here you can download the
trajectory data of debating taxicab and
the sparse sample the carbon monoxide
concentration for a few weeks I think
yeah yeah peace so you compare the using
the cell phone and I using the sensor
networks and use it using sensor network
is more scalable because you don't have
to push a lot of data to the saleswoman
cellular networks but if you're
considering just using apps because for
for your taxi cab experiments all you
are using is just a GPS data right so
which most all almost all the smartphone
have but you get a chip yeah if you push
on some app to to their smartphone using
software and then just help them upload
to a central database all the time then
it'd be more scalable than pushing
hardware's yep you're absolutely right
um I think my answer to your question is
are bi fold one is very beginning of the
system we want the module to be more
reliable than cost-efficient we just to
deploy a few hundreds of them we want
every set to be reliable and if the
smartphone app is ground to the taxicab
drivers we do not we cannot guarantee
the reliability of the data we collect
it that's one and number two it's a
technical problem most a smartphone has
the accelerometer microphone camera some
even with a gyro but they don't provide
temperature like carbon monoxide the
environmental sensors so we have to give
them the
either bluetooth-enabled sensors or some
wild sensors that will add a lot of
complexity to the deployment of the
system then we decide okay a few tens of
sensors that's develop the hardware and
give them and it's a install and we
don't care about the driver don't have
doesn't have to care about it and to
turn out to be easier way but you're
absolutely right in the future no to
make it the whole system's scalable we
may consider we have to consider the
smartphone apps as a solution to this so
and then did you find that your
pollution data match that of the u.s.
embassy collected data I don't know
actually one challenging point of the
system our Asian always is to make the
wake make the data public and and
transparent and people have the right to
know they're you know living condition
but you know we are using the
commercially available sensors having
the cost to consideration most a sensor
always very noisy readings so one
challenge point of that the Arizona
ceased to how to denoise the sensory
reading and to make it as close to the
ground choose as possible so the problem
I think the question here is how do we
how do we define the ground choose is a
very expensive equipment output is the
ground truth or people's feeling our
ground choose basically in the in the in
the application I I mentioned we are not
trying to reconstruct the distribution
of the air pollution what we are trying
to do is stretch just to to pinpoint the
source of the pollution and those are
our fact you cannot deny it there is an
there is an factory there is a there is
a core burning plans or something and
that that's something you cannot it's a
it's a binary it's a binary bit it's not
a reading so that's something we're
considering
to avoid you know that the reading
comparison it's hard to it's hard to
compare it all so approximately how much
does one sensor in the taxi cost
currently because the number are not so
large we have only 30 the cause is the
cost for each car box it's about six to
seven thousand I think Chinese Chinese
Chinese UN or even higher I'm not quite
sure because we do not calculate it but
we're currently consider a larger scale
deployment in shenzhen where we just got
a support from the local government for
we have established industry lab with
some local H engine manufacturer so we
decide to reduce the cost of each single
car box under 1000 not US dollars
chinese joint is about a 1 150 US
dollars approximately speaking so in
with that cost we can deploy about a
thousand bucks to the taxes inch engine
providing a finer-grained a sample of
the city in real time here did you do
these experiments like the sensing
actual measures because the reason I
wonder if they know amazing there's
serious influx in the summer month and
in October yeah when there's a lot of
stories 1005 for data
um the two data that I showed to you
were collected in May and yeah both of
them are collecting you may but I don't
think tourist is a big impact has a big
influence on the other pollution Cassie
truck pickup in drama and everything yes
yeah yeah oh the lord of the data set is
if you if you have the interest in
download the data set you see that the
trajectory data set cover both weekday
and weekend and public holidays in
public so basically you can see three
mode they we walking mode we can mode
and holiday mode I work with some of the
Beijing back CD de and we found very
difficult to do like not matching or
something like understanding like this
things are tough all over the place in
that because i'm going to say like they
often do it like we got stranger yeah um
do you mean in general i guess probably
different students working on this but
any general invited some like how to
deal with is almost than the ways and is
that one of the reasons you're going to
use maybe 30 boxes like a very much nor
do they have similar issues though the
same boxes are good it is a we developed
the hardware our own it's it's much
better than the very noisy yeah i agree
a we we had the same problem actually we
are still working on it it's not
completely resolved I'm assembler i'm
working with a professor leo guba said
computer science department working on
the denoising of the taxi the noisy taxi
trajectories i think there are two
reasons for the for the off-road driving
similarly in the data but it's not it's
not possible one is the road network
it's not accurate i I don't know what
road network data is at you are using
what we were using it the OpenStreetMap
some road are intentionally offset in
the in the in the Geo data set for
whatever reason it is is intentionally
offset so you have to work out some very
smart lyman the algorithm to drag those
align those data set back to the actual
road travel and another problem is the
the car box that covered one-third of
baking taxes are very old they were
divided by like 10 years ago and some of
them are not set properly so sometimes
they are just reporting wrong data we
saw that the data fly to Hawaii sometime
and back and forth like zigzag
trajectory it's not possible they are
not UFO so possible and sometime the
data the database are this problem they
interleave to trajectory together
confuse the car ID so that you can see
the interleaving so a lot of things
happening so must have some state of art
denoising algorithm to to wash the data
before it can be used actually useful
how could you get acceptance from the
tax accountant between so sensor to the
taxi or is there any therapy too much
patient that's come um well I think it's
a lot of options the data set we're
using for Beijing research is actually
coming from like a donation we have a
very good relation with the twisted with
the manager of the company and we asked
for the data set and they donate the one
month's data set to us and since we are
going to deploy a larger system inch
engine and be online constantly I think
there are two options one is through the
government order okay they can ask or
other set an order to the through the
company or partly only by the local
government to to be cooperative in the
research and the other is a
business basically what i'm thinking is
a we can develop a call a cab a
smartphone app or the for the taxi
company so that they can enjoy a better
appearance to their passengers and just
to punch your phone and then we can get
the data along the you go yes yes but we
still got a question on public policy
i'm curious what your goal down the line
be to decrease the motion in areas that
you find it and what would be the amount
of time that it would take to do
something like that in the example you
gave in southern beijing and there's a
source that you're traced to a chemical
plant or a factory would you be capable
of shutting that down or moving you my
best ending we are very cautious about
about saying something as a fact we just
say the indicating the data indicating
there might be some costs in that area
generating high concentration of carbon
monoxide then that is indicated by our
mobile sensing network but of course we
do not have the authority to do so and
we just generated report to the to the
to the say the government or two people
who are interested in this but it's not
conclusive yeah
you expand it later to other kinds of
pollution because a lot of Absolution
it's not carbon dioxide was very bad as
a bad yeah yeah yeah the problem is the
cost of the sensors for instance the
particular no matter 2.5 the sensor is
not it's not that cheap to access so we
have to balance carefully between the
number of samples and the cost of the
system that's at the reason yeah okay
with either the 30 boxes you're
installing I'm guessing that the party's
credits so at least here when you get my
taxicab most likely that taxicab is
retired at the end of the night and no
one uses in till next day so I wasn't
sure if that was a problem play because
if you installed on 30 cars in there
only used by drivers for like this one
particular period of the day then you're
screwed for the rest sir well lovely as
I said most Beijing taxi drivers are
really hard-working people um actually
they have the company charge based on
the num this on car not the working
hours so most cases there are two
drivers double shift they have to shift
one is the daytime in the nighttime so
you can basically see 24 by 7 mobility
yeah a to divert circles further and you
have the freedom in choosing the demand
the desired cars right you don't have to
deploy all of them
you did say it was like 13,000 cars 9 30
30 days the car CD quality sensors and
the sons are is lessons in something a
computer scientist said somewhere
between twenty seven thousand of the
8,000 collected we sir reporting their
locations to directories can you kind of
a stupid sensors not into purple one box
like Kevin Henson says ever transmitting
hub I mean Cabos I owe ahran teens you
can try to insert into one box and go
that sensor into the ability to it yeah
so um violence in disra's answers each
other space broken you will tell
speaking I can communicate each other or
and Rosa and Amy told you and we have
some relation so I so probably your
sensors are right for right timing right
now but probably the more problems will
happen and then you need paste or more
sensors in 30 parts yes so they have a
situation will be helpin a creature so
by there is a new civilization and from
hating each other and be mobile so you
try to come I think that's absolutely a
good idea because it's a very clever
idea as a matter of fact if the roadside
sensor is a number of the rules I sense
or density of Rose I sensor increase we
will more and more likely to reach such
a situation that sensors can talk to
each other can form some sort of ad hoc
network until one of at least one of
them reach the sink or the mobile
carriers it increase the probability of
a successful delivery right it's very
very practical
are you working with any others regions
across these assumptions and that
Stefan's technologies are highly
congested curly yes how many suggestions
yes I think you said at the beginning I
want to clarify this that you're using
zigbee short range in order to prevent
congestion over the bigger Network right
yes and if you use cellular phones that
would be a lot of congestion yes look
exactly exactly well column we
originally consider this problem from
the informations theoretical aspect for
you you have a constraint bandwidth
resources how can you use it wisely of
course spatial reuse in terms of power
reduction it's a good solution you can
use the same frequency a bandwidth
resources again and again again as long
as you you talk to each other in such a
way that nobody else can hear it that's
that we're in good position and cellular
you cannot do that there is a power up
there you have to talk to yell to to
reach it and
alright well thank you everyone for
coming section name you have come join
us again for the rest of a consecutive
aerospace progress that's quarter next
week we'll be inviting a president of
toray industries an inch of the top SMF
carbon fiber nanotechnologies have been
working on an application within the
airline industries of the bottom of your
shoe so we feel joy the Sun thank you
again festival
you